Hi,
I'm here at the airport in Portland,
about 50 cities into what is going to be
100 city tour.
It's going exceptionally well.
Audiences in each city and the people
I've met afterward and being very
enthusiastic.
There seems to be a rapidly developing
market for relatively long form
intellectual discourse driven by Youtube
and podcasts which have none of the
bandwidth limitations of traditional
media forms.
I just had two evenings of productive
discussion with Sam Harris in Vancouver
who going to post my notes from those
talks on my blog@JordanPeterson.com.
We talked about the relationship between
facts and values and the role that
narrative and story might play in
bringing the two together for better or
worse,
the Vancouver event sold out.
The next discussion was Sam the third,
which will also feature Douglas Murray
will take place in Dublin,
Ireland on the 14th of July at the three
arena,
followed by the final fourth discussion
at the o two arena in London.
On the 16th.
Tickets for those discussions are still
available.
You can find them at the events page on
my website.
That's Jordan b Peterson Dotcom,
or in the written description of this
video below all the discussions with Sam
are being filmed and will be released in
video and podcast form within the next
few months after the remaining two
discussions in Dublin and London because
of the positive response from audiences
and from individual audience members,
I've added another 19 cities to the 12
rules to are these include Rochester
Westbury,
Wallingford,
Baltimore,
Durham,
Miami,
Orlando,
St Petersburg and Jacksonville,
Cincinnati and Cleveland,
Grand Rapids des Moines,
St Louis,
Kansas City,
Denver,
Colorado Springs,
San Antonio,
and irving.
You can get presale tickets using the
code Dr Jay bp until Thursday,
June 28th at 10:00 PM.
Tickets go on sale to everyone.
Friday,
June 29th at 10:00 AM.
I'm also touring Canada in July and
August dates,
locations and ticket links are also
listed below in the video description
and available at Jordan b Peterson
Dotcom.
Finally,
I'll be speaking in about a dozen cities
in Europe in October and November and
Australia in February.
Those venues and dates will be announced
in the next few weeks.
Thanks for watching or listening.
I'm looking forward to seeing you
potentially add one of these lectures by
for now,
from Portland.